it's the biggest joy in my life it's the
realest love and I can't even there's no
words I can explain it I can show you
better than I can tell you yeah I love
you
[Music]
this is the best father-son relationship
on the planet Earth how much do you love
this little boy I mean I love him so
much his mommy loves him so much
my whole family loves them and the world
loved them and and God gave me my
biggest blessing yes boy I love boy
that's what and that's why I named my
album grateful yeah yeah you're saying
and he's the executive producer the
executive producer and he did an amazing
job and the album is officially out and
I love you boy CJ I don't know if you've
been taking me and mommy always keep
them around greatness we always give
them joy we always give them happiness
how do you get this suit made and who
made that suit Gucci made it one mommy
took him to the Gucci store and got
butyou to cheer him up and got him a
custom Gucci and Gucci man is wearing
the same suit as Assad and Gucci wearing
Gucci
so Gucci and Gucci and a sila to the
picture earlier is classic side and
Gucci boy and sadly you big Ike
therefore what is the next thing that's
coming and we'll wit where else will we
see a sign what's that gonna be
everywhere cuz he's legend he's a legend
already he's an icon and you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna I gotta say I'm gonna
give him so much joy so much happiness
forever I work for him you want to go
ahead and do this but don't take my job
yet don't take my job you can have the
microphone but please don't take my job
look he's got it look yes would you like
the newest correspondent for
Entertainment Tonight yeah
I was ready for that he dropped the
money he did what he was supposed to do
he dropped the mic
[Music]